the Market Square is a popular meeting
place in Lima many famous people were at
home here the Renaissance painters Lucas
Khanna the elder and younger lived in
this building but it's mainly the
classicists from vemma that attract many
visitors to come here
that's kinda sweet I gotta go internet
gets plan you know let's stroll a bit
further we invite more love to just
amble along Vemma is a city for
pedestrians the sites are close together
the architecture reflects the city's
feudal days that's its ISTE applets demo
this is democracy square it used to be
called first in plots or Dukes square
that's very fitting because it's
surrounded by royal buildings gaben
confussed a single boy there are the
so-called red and yellow palaces then
the first in house where Duke carl's
Augustus lived and next to it is a small
palace that's been a library for
centuries
the Dowager Duchess Anna Amalia whose
name it bears supported the library
decisively many treasures are to be
found here and there's a first
indication of Johann Wolfgang von
Goethe's presence in the city he ran a
library for decades right next to it the
park on the inn was created in the 18th
century it's renowned for its valuable
trees and architectural gems like the
ruins of the temple and house
Goethe also played a part in designing
the park
he spent his first years in Vienna in
this house call oak was thought in
theses house King Charles Augustus gave
him this house as a gift because he
wanted Goethe to stay in vimar as a
homeowner Goethe was eligible for
citizenship of vimar and Charles
Augustus was sure good to would remain
in the city for a while so he achieved
his name after 1782 good who lived in
this house on phone plan many of its
rooms look the way they did in the last
year's of the poet's life
the study in which he wrote works such
as Faust is unchanged good estate in
vemma until his death in 1832 for good
who had a syphilitic part of its charm
for Goethe was certainly that it wasn't
too big but it was manageable it also
provided him with a political sphere of
activity in addition to poetry and
literature encephalitic avanced Goodis
interests were many and varied he was a
poet government official dabbler in
science and Traveller he wrote for
nature's like mine a journey is
invaluable it animates corrects
instructs and develops
the composer Franz Liszt spent many
summers in this house in a pond ina
infants list had a close friendship with
Grand Duke Charles Alexander and the
Grand Duke managed to get him to return
to high Mar and what's the best way to
do that give him a house
wimpy mothma dozen peasant munching in
ein house here the celebrated musician
taught young gifted pianists from all
over Europe for free
the next stop is where four additional
lived an assembly Brad Schiller and good
together good start by in school to get
into a conversation with Friedrich
Schiller and was fascinated so he
invited Schiller to vimar by myungin odd
from that moment and intense creative
association existed between them by edon
an intensify - spoons Weimar classicism
can be traced to the Dowager Duchess an
Amalia who lived in the widow's palace
she was a very well educated and
ambitious woman
she hosted illustrious social gatherings
there among the guests were of course
Goethe and Schiller who now attract
attention as a memorial in front of the
National Theatre he awarded gizumon here
people sang and made such music that the
angels in heaven were truly delighted
that's the anger in him ooh you have
evolved oh boy that's fun huh
and I hope you've been delighted by our
city tour through Vimal thank you for
your attention and goodbye thanks for
your open up some kind of